[音楽]
こんにちははじめ社長です
the first take
一発録りで歌ってみたいと思います
今日た宇野はオフィシャルひげダンディズムさんの i love
という歌でめちゃくちゃ好きでたまに歌ってみたりしてるんですけども
あの高が高すぎて手ないんですよ
致命的なまでなんですけどなの好きなんで歌ってみたいと思います
宜しくお願いします
うん
ええええええ
can
car
[音楽]
北館見つめる消しの
そのなくに君が入ってから変わり果てた目回わー
いつもそつなくんこの子た日々のなんだか不思議な引力に逆らえず崩れてく
間
なんていいかけては矢部て j
パイバーン肺がん何度を大
だが丸ああああ
か1信者の中
三善堂香川いく
n だ
マルゲ水槽の中に飛び込んで溶けた絵の具美談なぁ
いいいい
ni
ani
me
[音楽]
eenie
me
ほどだ時計
君に良い買ってたらん
あいらー
そうだかんだけど僕
じゃ yeah
ブーブー言っん
[音楽]
とぅ言えないものを見て笑う
キビのことをはから音ない僕がいる
うつ貸すっきて目がくらんんねしま
今もうネット空見子ば誰で生きている
ああああああ
前田
深粉結び目
ああああああ
アイガーで際ぶりでにつけてー
やーを取り入れから待って
僕は繰り返してる何度も
れぷりーぱぱああああ
ああああああ
dai
[音楽]
ni
me
色の街の中で像
by らー
どうぞ赤白だってしめてる
[音楽]
goo
rar
持って ano ang
ni
retain
おった感情のだ母
また昨日はず火葬の合間に君がくれたプレゼントはこの
だけに優しい世界だ
deai
ひどいだなあー
いいと気づけなかった
me
aname
たことが撮ってる君に良いかってだ
マイラーとおっ
zan
[音楽]
uno
僕ら
名前もなぁよるが受けて弾く
[音楽]
bl